la primera cita electoral desde el
inicio de la pandemia en colombia deja a
la izquierda como clara vencedora la
coalición del pacto histórico liderada
por el ex alcalde de bogotá gustavo
petro irrumpió con fuerza en el congreso
de la república con 16 escaños en el
senado empata sin embargo con el
tradicional partido conservador ambos
seguidos de cerca por el liberal el
partido de gobierno el centro
democrático salió mal herido de los
comicios el pacto histórico también se
hizo con 25 escaños en la cámara de
representantes
el mejor
progresismo en la historia de la
república de color estamos ad portas
a la presidencia de colombia
[Aplausos]
petro consolidó sus aspiraciones
presidenciales barriendo en la consulta
interpartidista de la izquierda con más
de 44 millones de votos la sorpresa sin
embargo fue francia márquez la feminista
y ambientalista afro obtuvo casi 800.000
votos superando incluso las votaciones
de los principales aspirantes en otras
coaliciones vamos
de la resiste o sea el poder hasta que
la dignidad
acostumbré a la derecha tampoco
sorprendió la victoria de federico
gutiérrez con más de 2 millones de votos
se plantó como la opción de la coalición
del conservador equipo por colombia
lucharemos para que en colombia no se
repliquen proyectos fallidos que muchos
de nuestros vecinos hoy justamente
padecen el candidato de centro sergio
fajardo obtuvo una votación muy por
debajo de sus rivales evidenciando la
fragmentación de su coalición centro
esperanza
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la polarización sigue siendo la tónica
en colombia y las legislativas pueden
marcar el rumbo de lo que sucederá el
próximo 29 de mayo con las elecciones
presidenciales